ufc 257 delivered a blow and by blow i  mean a knockout shot  analysis before the mcgregor poirier  fight was that dustin poirier needed to  work hard to get this bout to the later  rounds  if he wanted a chance well the main  event didn't see the third round because  the second  ended with a bang all eyes run mcgregor  as he made his way into the octagon for  the first time in a year but  more eyes should have been on dustin  poirier's knockout punch in the second  round poirier wastes no time  louisiana and since cajun crush fist  into connor's head  mcgregor is knocked out for the first  time in his career  poirier wins the lightweight main event  fight  island what a stunner